Hi guys, we're about to do the show. How do you feel today? Oh, right now today I feel pretty good. Great, you sound like it. Oh, welcome to Smartless. Yeah. Give us a chance to catch our breath. Lattice. Smart. Lattice. Smart. Lattice.
Oh, well he's like really sensitive and kind of like, he's like delicate today, he's like very delicate. I am, you're picking up on a vibe. Yeah, you're super delicate. We know who you are. Backward tat kind of vibe, like it's great. You know, just. You're picking up on a vibe. Yeah. You're super delicate. We know who you are. Backward tat kind of vibe. Like it's great.
You know, just... Took it off. Hair is getting a little long. He's an artist. Little. He's an artist and he didn't get much sleep last night. It's like Crystal Gale over there. Dude.
Right? Bennett, I don't know what you're doing, but you are dialed. You are dialed, dude. Here comes J.J.'s back. You're picking up on a fire. There you are. There he is. Bellissima.
Okay. Will is sensitive today and tired today. He's a sensitive, tired little boy. It's true. Well, it's Sunday morning. Well, no, it's Sunday afternoon. It's lunchtime where you are, Willie. Yeah.
Great week, long, late nights. Shauny was there. Do some. Sean, he was there. Do some nights? Yeah, Sean, he was there. Few nights in a row. Oh yeah, Sean, you did a little work this week too, with Will? That was fun though, it was really fun,
some really good laughs. It was really fun, wasn't it? Yeah. Oh my God, we had some good laughs. Oh, did you guys really work the scenes? Huh? Was it magic? I mean, yes, yes, first of all, yes.
It was it. It was good. It was it. And then we had a couple moments we had, we're sitting around this table that's all done up, you know, the props have put the food out and stuff and Sean picks up these noodles and goes, somebody said something goes, that's really low, man. So dumb. So dumb.
We were all trying to think of like Chinese food puns. And he was so dumb. Was it on camera or was it just in between setups? No, no, no. It was just in between setups. And we were just laughing because it's so dumb. Everybody's giddy because it's one in the morning or whatever. Yeah.
And then he was... And then Sean said, oh, we got dinner. He goes, I got a meal with somebody this week tomorrow. And I go, oh, a dinner? He goes, no, lunch. I try to keep my dinners free, and I said, free of what, vegetables? I said, free of what, vegetables?
Did you get any of this on camera, or is it just for your own? No, but that was pretty funny. No, but that was pretty funny. That was funny. Well, you were about to say something about Pete, the great Pete Thorell. Oh yeah, Pete Thorell is an absolute all-star.
He's the best, I love that guy. Yeah, he's incredible. A total stud. So fasturrell's an absolute all-star. He's the best, I love that guy. Yeah, he's incredible. A total fad. So fast, he's the first AD. He's the, for Tracy, that's the guy basically just keeps everything on track and running and for everybody in this. This guy runs the show.
Yeah, and so it was like one in the morning and everybody's so tired and not in the mood for any jokes and Pete was just talking about how the scenes goes and I said, hey Pete, he goes, yeah, I go, can you keep your process inside because we can all hear it. And we have enough to think about.
Did he laugh? For a second, yeah, he laughed, but for a second on his face he was like, he thought he was serious. And I could see that Pete's like, is this guy really saying this to me? Yeah. It's so complicated what he was running.
And Sean just did it in front of everybody. Hey Pete, like a cross, the set. Can you just keep, you're vocalizing outside your process. Pete Thorell, one of the all-time greats. Jay, he came from you, he was a recommend from you. Yeah, that's- Because you worked with him, and he's just the greatest. Yeah, Pete and I have done a ton of stuff together.
It's my first AD and things that I've directed. He's just like... He's so great. He's so great. So you guys have worked together a lot. We've done, we did Family Fang together. We did three or four seasons of Ozark together. We did the outsider together.
He was the first AD every episode of Ozark, those first three, four? No, no, no, he alternated with, you rotate, there's two of them. Oh, right, there's two. But I get Pete on everything I direct, if he's available, but he's very fancy now, he's working with a bunch of directors that make me look like a little punk,
which I am. Which is weird, he works together a lot, because he said I'm his favorite, he's ever, anyway, it doesn't matter. I literally take work just so I could work with Pete. Like I really don't care what the script is. Yeah, he's a hundred. I now get it.
He's incredible. He's an incredible dude. Anyway, the great Pete Threep. So wait, so Willie, I wanted to wait to share this with you today, because I already told Jason last Sunday that this is one of the craziest things that happened to me. So, Scotty and I, we're looking at real estate in Brooklyn,
and we go see this new townhouse, not that we can afford it, we just were like, let's see what's around. And my broker was like, you should see what's around. Anyways, it's a beautiful townhouse, it was crazy, it was like five floors. And so we're walking, we're walking, we're walking all the way upstairs,
we get to the top of the stairs, totally out of breath. And I'm like, okay, great, let's just move on to things that are real. Because walking up five flights of stairs is just, it's not even in the real world. No, no, not five flights of stairs, no. So Scotty goes, let's ride the elevator down. I'm like, okay.
So we got him, me and Scotty get on the elevator with one of our realtors and Linda is her name, she's great. And so it's like shoulder to shoulder, this like, postage-sized size. Hey Linda, if you Linda is her name, she's great. And so it's like shoulder to shoulder, this like postage size. Hey Linda, if you're out there, apparently you're great. Sorry, good for you Linda. You're part of the team. One of our Reel Itters.
Go ahead, so you're in the fucking elevator in a townhouse. This is a hashtag relatable, keep going. But wait, so Willie, the doors close, the gates close, I press the button, doesn't move. Open the door, won't open. Press the button again, we're shoulder to shoulder. And now even in 10 seconds in, I'm like, this isn't,
I was freaking out. And 30 seconds, one minute, five minutes, she's calling the realtor, Scotty's blood sugar's dropping like crazy that they're double arrows. I was like, okay, so he's going to die in here. I'm going to, like, it was crazy. And so I yelled through the door, I'm like, call 911.
So they call 911. They call 911. The fire. So the firefighters come and just, now we're like, 30 seconds is a long time to be stuck in something with that small space. So now you got a boner. Right.
Makes it even worse. That would have fixed it. So you think 30 seconds is long, So you'd think 30 seconds is long or a minute. We were in there for like 10, 15 minutes. It was great. I had to squat down and like breathe. I was going crazy. So, of course, hey Will, is the gum good?
Does it taste good? Because it sounds awesome. It's not me. It's just a podcast, you know? Unreal. Sorry, keep going, Sean. This is awesome. I'm at the end of the story.
So as the firefighters pull up, there is a latch in the door. I pushed it, the door opened. I got out. That's it. And you're out. And you... And Scotty made it okay?
We're not too sure. He's still in the box. I love that. Jason feigned interest. Is Scotty okay? Is Scotty good? Okay, let's get to the game. How's Linda's data plan? I'm dead. And so you passed on this one. Back in the SUV. Did you ask if you could put it in an escalator? Oh God, is that funny?
All right, let's get to our guest. Jesus Christ. You guys, we're all big, big fans of this guy. He's amazing. I'm not, I'm not, I'm not. I'm not. I'm not. I'm not.
I'm not. I'm not. I'm not. I'm not. I'm not. That's funny. All right, let's get to our guest. Jesus Christ. You guys, we're all big, big fans of this guy. He's amazing. I'm not committing to that yet. I promise you are. I don't know who it is. And it was such an honor when he was a guest of ours in Will and Grace.
Before becoming the beloved Hollywood treasure that we know today, he used to write affirmations in the shower asking God to let him be an actor. Spoiler alert, God delivered. But before that, he was peddling office supplies to correction facilities in between auditions. Today, when he's not recording amazing jazz albums,
you can see him being wizardly in one of the hottest blockbusters this year is the incredibly talented and utterly delightful Jeff Goldblum. Oh yes, I am a fan of Jeff Goldblum. Yes, I am a fan as well. Helloum. Yes, I am a fan as well. Yes. Baba.
The best, the best. Hi, I'm literally crying. Jeff. Sean, I'm so happy to be here. I'm so happy to be here. I love you all so. By the way, where are you? You know where I am?
In our apartment in Florence, Italy. Wow. So, another hashtag relatable. Jeffrey's doing very well. You don't have an elevator in there, do you? Oh my God. Yes. You do? Yes, we do.
It's a couple of floors. It's very, very nice. But I want to be relatable. No, we've been living here for the last couple of years. A few years, our two kids, seven and nine, two boys are going to school here. Lise Frances, my wife is from Toronto, she speaks French to them.
They speak now three languages, because they speak Italian. Will is from Toronto. I know he is, I have much to ask. I'm so interested in you guys, I adore you, I adore this show. And just your little tet-a-tet-a-tet before I came on. My coffee chat.
Yeah, your coffee chat. I love so much and I love this show. But you know what I love, it reminded me, is people making each other laugh. I, if I have my druthers, I oftentimes, if I really need a lift, I'll go on YouTube and see the blooper reels for, I oftentimes, if I really need a lift, I'll go on YouTube and see the blooper reels for, I have my favorites, Julie Louis Dreyfus on Seinfeld.
I love the way she laughs, Larry David. I love the way he laughs, Ricky Gervais, all these people have been on your show, of course. When Larry David laughs, his jaw becomes unhinged. And he's, yeah, yeah. Yes, yeah. That's so great, I love it. It is true, the bloopers from things,
it is really fun to watch, because you know it's coming, and so you watch the people as it surprises them, it sneaks up on them, and then they try to hold it together, and then it's full release. It's always funny. Better phrase than that.
I love it, hey, how about, and then I sometimes, because my algorithm and then it's full release. It's always funny. Better phrase than that. Hey, how about, and then I sometimes, because my algorithm knows I like it, I guess, I see bloopers from 1930s. And so you see, you know, Barbara Stanwyck and Humphrey Bogart, you know, forgetting, Betty Davis forgetting their lines. I've seen that.
And swearing, isn't that interesting? Doesn't that make them? I don't think I've ever seen anybody curse in black and white. No, me neither, I've never seen that, no. Yeah, it's kind of interesting. I mean, I love behind the scenes of all kinds. One of my little obsessions is to go on now, the device,
and you can see interviews with everybody about the craft and directors and actors, and these podcasts, we have to talk about that. If we were really at dinner, and we could talk for a few hours, I feel like I have so much to talk to you guys about that we need to be pithy on all these issues. But I would like to talk about the history of talk shows
and the new podcast phenomenon of which you guys are now the kings of the hill and the forum which allows us to know you and to know all your guests. So thank you for that, because I know there are people I like particularly on your show that I now know better than ever. I just saw a play, we just came back,
sorry if I'm too self-starting and chatty, but I'm excited. We just came back from a little weekend trip, leaving the kids here with their helper, with good people, and we saw two plays, and we went to a gallery in London, and saw Goya and the... Wait, with their helper, a couple of good people. Go ahead.
Helpers, yeah, I know. Yeah. They're good people. No, they're good, and they did a very good job. And, but my point is that Kate Blanchett, we saw in The Seagull. Oh, how is that? I'm doing The Barbican right after her.
Oh, I wanna hear all about that and I wanna talk about theater, I wanna talk about Oscar Levin. But The Barbican, I'd never heard of, I'd never been in. It's a very beautiful theater. Yeah. And it was one of the, I mean, The Seagull,
I'd seen my parents who liked that. Well, my parents who took us to see art films in the, when I was a teenager, in the mid-60s, et cetera, I then, only this last weekend, remembered that I saw a movie made by Sidney Lomet of the Seagull with Vanessa Redgrave and et cetera, and you know, a lot of people people that I want to go and revisit. Anyway, we saw this play.
Take me with you. Oh my gosh, Emma Corrin was Nina in it. She was the mother, if you know the play. And at the end, we went back to see the actors, all of them, it's a lovely cast, and it's one of my favorite things about a theater experience, going back, even though I love this three hour show.
But I went back, everybody was lovely. I met Emma Corrin, da da da da. And then Kate herself allowed us to come back. She couldn't have been lovelier. I've crossed paths with her. We've been in a couple of movies, never had scenes together. But I saw her in another play anyway.
For the second time, I went back, the first time was after she did Blanche Dubois in Streetcar Named Desire, which I saw it, bam. But I went back this time and I just burst, I blubbered, I burst into the deepest tears. I do that too when I see something great, I really get moved, yeah. Or some Lo Mein.
Or some Lo Mein. Yes. That was really Lo Mein. Well, I want to talk about you guys, I really get moved, yeah. Or some Lo Mein. Or some Lo Mein. Yes. That was really Lo Mein. Well, I want to talk about you guys, about food to you guys too. I love Lo Mein, I love all manner of food. We have to talk about that. But, and then my other,
the point that I was really getting at is that we tuned into your show, because I'm doing all my research. I heard about your show, but it's mostly since I've had this assignment in the last couple of weeks that I've been immersed in it. I've heard many, many things, I've, hours and hours and hours, including her thing.
And so the point is, I learned more about her, and I felt like it was the best interview, and the way you guys do it, it allows us not only to know you, but your guests in a very beautiful way. We can't wait to get to know you today, Jeff Goldblum. Here comes Sean's podcast character. Every time I hear like the seagull,
I'm reminded of that line from Whithnell and I, and he says, I loathe those Russian plays. They're always filled with women staring out of windows, whining about ducks going to Moscow. Anyway. Is that true? That's funny. It's a brilliant line, isnining about ducks going to Moscow. Anyway. Is that true? That's funny. It's a brilliant line, isn't it?
It's brilliant. How do you know that verbatim? Bruce Robinson, I've seen that film thousands of times with Nell and I think it's the most perfect film of all time. Do you know, for years I have heard about that film and I saw the first 15 minutes, it wasn't because of the movie, And I saw, the first 15 minutes,
it wasn't because of the movie. I took an exit ramp and I haven't gone in, so I've never seen it, really. And I know people highly esteem that, like you do, I know. I went down the same ramp, I haven't been back yet. I'd like to. So you and I will do a double feature. We'll see the Lamette piece and with Nail and I.
When are you back in the country? Me and you? Yo, yo, yo. I'd love, love to. Boy, what a reaction. Me, what? Me and you. I thought you were talking to your confreres.
No, I'd love to go to. I know, I'm looking at my schedule now and it's really tight right through Christmas. Let's go to the movies, let's do many things. You know, you're my favorite, you're my best friends now, you know. We'll be right back. And now back to the show.
Now, Jeff, I wanna talk about this thing about, I poll anyone who will answer this thing about going backstage when you go see the play on Broadway. And apologies to the listener, this is hashtag not relatable again. Ongoing thing. So there's this thing where- Well, Sean did it the other night, Jason, by the way.
Sean did it the other night at- Glengarry and Russ. Yeah, well, okay, so now I didn't, okay? I went, I saw Glengarry last week as well. And now I don't know those actors except for the fact that they have been on the show. Now I don't feel like- You know Bob, you know Bob Odenkirk a little bit.
I've talked to Bob at a couple of parties, but I don't think that counts in order to, what I think, is disruptive and potentially annoying to an actor that's just finished a two hour performance. I know, you can't tell, it's a fine line. Now they have to like meet and greet and like play host to a bunch of people backstage they don't know except for the fact
that they are also famous. But are you planning on being a handful? Is that what it is? Well no, but what are you gonna come back, are you gonna hear like, oh you were so great, oh thank you so much. Right, you can't tell if it's work for them and they want that, or they don't want that and they want to go home.
But Sean, as you pointed out, as you pointed out, you are made, generally, you're made aware, the stage manager will come and say, so and so and so and so and so and so is in the house. And what happens is Jason, so a lot of those people, they are fans of yours and they respect you and what you've done for some reason. And then they say, he's out there tonight. And then they go, and then they're backstage
and they're like, because it's become de rigueur to do that, if you don't do it, also the opposite is true. They go, this guy, Big Shot Bateman as he's known, he rolls in, puts his eyeballs on us. We pour it out for hours with our snappy dialogue, mammoth dialogue, and our wonderful blocking that we're doing and everything.
It's like this orchestra, and this guy's, he's in an Uber back to the Greenwich Hotel. Now, but now really, Jeff and Sean, and let me. I'm with you, Jay, I'm 50-50. Like when I did Oscar, I went straight home only because I couldn't do it. It was just too much and shaking hands. I didn't want to get sick, and you know what I mean?
Oh, so you instructed the stage manager, no guests. Yeah, well guests, like if they were friends, I knew. They could come backstage, but I didn't want to go out to the crowd after. Jeff, what do you think? I'm glad we're talking about this. Because things always change. And it was an issue the other night.
I'm 50-50 with you. I know exactly what both of you are saying. I want to be sensitive. It's very true what you're saying, Jason, but it's also true what you're saying, Will. And I always think, oh boy, they know I'm here. You know, I should go back, da da da da da. But oftentimes I want to go back.
But the other night, and this is a three hour version of the Seagull, and they do eight shows a week. And yes, I can well imagine they don't. And so when I, as I guess is the way to do it, contact the nearest person with a bag who looked like, an usher, da da da da, or the house manager comes up, I said, is it okay, how can we, will it be okay if, would it be, you know, I don't wanna bother anybody,
but what if we wanna go back, et cetera, et cetera. At first, there seemed to be, in this case, and it was uncommon, I hadn't encountered it before, they said, here's what they did, they were like, hmm, already making, hmm, faces, et cetera, et cetera. So I made it clear right away, I got the picture, and I said, okay, I get it.
Well, whatever works, if it would be nice for us to go back, we're available, but please, I don't wanna bother anybody, or if that's not cool, then I wanna help serve them, et cetera, et please, I don't wanna bother anybody, or if that's not cool, I wanna help serve them, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera. Anyway, by the end, she said yes, sent him back, and she was very nice. I was very aware of the time I went, oh my gosh,
I was blubbering, but also excusing myself quickly. I said, here, this is Emily, my wife, and all so great, and goodbye, goodbye, go home, and da-da-da-da-da. And that was it. So it was a whole, yeah, so I'm glad we're having this conversation. Because it is a thing.
Ultimately, ultimately I think it's better to air on the side of going back because it's a nice thing to do and what actor doesn't like to get like, hey, great job. Well, what about, should I do a follow up then with, because Kieran and Bill and Bob, I guess it would be appropriate for me to potentially text them. Should I text them?
That's nice. I would definitely do what you always do, which is have Amanda write something up and then you send it. Hey, hey. But Sean, how was it going back? Were they receptive? Oh my God, it was so fun and easy
and they loved it and they loved people to come back there and I was hanging out with Karen and Karen poured me a they love people to come back there and I was hanging out with Karen and Karen poured me a glass of whiskey to share with him and Something like so we heard Bateman was here last week. What's his problem? Your name was not brought up I good once they all love so much. Nobody wants to bring your name up Because see I like I think it's presumptuous to for me to think that they know I'm in the audience and or that they want To see you right? I know it's tricky, it's tricky. Listen, listen, listen, we're not gonna solve it today,
but what I want to get to, because we mentioned Toronto, your wife being from Toronto and French and stuff, but what I want to get to, and I've always, I've never been able to talk to you about it, we've only sort of run into each other a handful of times, we don't know each other, Jeff, I'm a massive fan of yours, like everybody else, I just think that you're just incredible.
Great, thank you, me too, me too. You also worked with a very prominent and prolific and talented, genius Canadian director by the name of David Cronenberg when you made The Fly. Yes, sir. What a film. I love that film. Can you, now, talk a little bit about that process
of working with David Cronenberg, if you might. Yes, I might and I will, and here I go. I love him. Here's what happened. What happened, it was 1986-ish, I think. This script came to me. I was immediately struck by it. Did I, there wasn't a, I met him.
Was there a reading? I don't think so, we met and da da da da and they offered it to me. And then, yeah, and it was great. He was wonderful, he was the most proactive I'd been creatively at that point. I had, I worked on it like I always do conscientiously but I was very passionate about it. I wanted to make it, like I always do conscientiously, but I was very passionate about it.
I wanted to make it work. I had a big feeling about it. And he, as you've probably heard, even though he makes those wild movies, is a very buttoned up, kind of sweet Canadian, civil, polite, delightful, smart, intellectual artist who marches to his own drum, of course. And that movie, I'd seen all his other movies, the one prior to that was the one with Chris Walken,
Dead Zone, which I liked a lot. Uh-huh, yeah, that's great. I used to always do this, Dead Zone, I wanna do a remake of Dead Zone, but when the guy, you know, he grabs the arm and he can see the future, right? He touches people and he can kind of see their future. I wanted to do a remake when he grabs people,
but all he can see is he can give you traffic updates. So he grabs you and he goes, don't take the 405. You know what I mean? You know what I mean? That's good, I'd like to say that. So it was great, so we rehearsed and then, and you know, Chris Wales, who won the Oscar for the special effects makeup, and David,
and I got together and did these elaborate camera tests which they had designs and da da da da. And it was five hours finally in makeup. But he was great and we went from scene to scene. And actually, I had a vigorous conversation with him about the ending. There was an ending which had painted me retroactively in a kind of villainous,
even though I tried to kill her at the end and meld all three of us. And then she goes with this guy, John Getz. She kind of gets with him finally. And by that time I had so kind of, I was such an advocate and a passionate protector of my character, I was possessive and I didn't want her to wind up with him.
Wow. And I said, you know, wait a minute, wait a minute, couldn't it be that, et cetera, et cetera, I had some dumb idiot conversations, who was I to talk to him about that, but as it be that, et cetera, et cetera. I had some dumb idiot conversations, who was I to talk to him about that? But as it turns out, it kind of wound up ending kind of like that with her killing me. We don't have that aftermath where the bad guy's gone and she's now with this other guy.
So I was happy about that. But it was a very arduous, but lovely, passionate experience, et cetera, et cetera. I could tell you much about it. It's a great film. It really about it. It's a great film. It really loved it. It's a great film. Do you think that was the one that kind of really,
I mean, you've done tons of work before then. Was that the movie that put you over the top or Invasion of the Body Snatchers or what was the one that kind of like was? Big Chill was before that, right? Oh, Big Chill, right, Big Chill. Yes, yes, it was stepping stone to one thing led to another and luckily, because I was, like my teacher, Sandy Meisner said, it takes 20 years
to even call yourself an actor. Now luckily I had right away, miraculously, good, some parts, but small parts that led to bigger parts and I felt like I was learning and, you know, I guess career-wise, even though that hasn't been my focus, you know, from the start, one thing did lead to another. So yeah, there was, well, I worked with Altman
and I did that movie Nashville, very little part. California Split, yeah. That was nice to be in, in California Split. But then Invasion of the Body, so naturally there's Philip Kaufman, fantastic. And I did a movie in 76 before that with Joan Micklin Silver that I got some attention for and that led to some other things.
Actually, Lawrence Kestin saw that and I think that's what led him to be attracted to putting me in the big chill, which led to, yeah, now we're up to the fly and you know, et cetera, et cetera. We're up to. But wait, so. Any truth to you doing the prequel, the maggot?
No? Yeah. Jesus. Nice, Jason. Yeah, Jason, good for you, dude. You give me a little bit of time, I will work on some stuff, yeah. No, but you know, you have done, you have played, you have done so,
you've been very prolific and you've made a lot of films, and so I always want to know, we always sort of ask, what was the first thing, you talked about your parents taking you to see film when you were a teenager, which is great, so I'm sure of asked, what was the first thing, you talked about your parents taking you to see film when you were a teenager, which is great. So I'm sure that that maybe you tell us inspired you, but what was your first professional gig where you went, I'm gonna do this,
and then you actually went out and did it and worked and did a job? Good question. It was a wild adventure of the heart when I was 10 years old. The seed was sort of planted. I got the bug. I was in this camp, gaga gaga.
I was a part of this drama show. And my dad had already said, if you find something you love to do, that might be a vocational lighthouse and compass. Something clicked in me after this kind of thing when I was 10. and I thought to myself and kept secret to myself, this is what I want to do. I had it then.
This was a theater camp? No. You know, it was a Chatham in Pittsburgh where I'm from, Music Day Camp it was called. It wasn't sleepover, it was six weeks, and they had, I loved this group of people that was different and more my family than the kids I'd gone to school with. And I seemed to excel at art and piano
and badminton and softball and arts and crafts. And they had this acting little moment in the day. And at the end of the six weeks, they cast me in this Gilbert and Sullivan takeoff thing where I'd sang and I was the lead in that, and I kind of rehearsed with my mom and da da da da, and I leaped, leapt on stage, which was my first entrance, and that was it, and I got some laughs,
and it was fun, it was exhilarating, and it was after that that they said, hey, how'd you like that? And I went, I like that, I like that. But I kept it. That drug. Did that inform high school choices and college choices, no?
Well, here's what happened, briefly. The, between ninth and 10th and 10th and 11th grades in Pittsburgh, there was a six week offering at Carnegie Mellon University in art and I'd had some flair for that and then music, da da da da. And my mom was taking me through the brochure and she said, you want to go to this thing? I said, yeah.
She said, well, they have this acting thing. I said, maybe, maybe the acting thing. Maybe I'll do that. Really? Yes. Well, I did that and I was by the end of that Maybe this, the acting thing, maybe I'll do that, really? Yes, well, I did that and I was, by the end of that, and I did it for two years running, I was deeply in love with that campus and acting.
And that's when I started to write on the shower door every morning, please God let me be an actor. And then I tried out for that school, they turned me down. I gave a couple of bad auditions to get into the school. They turned me down. I gave a couple of bad, you know, I gave a bad audition to get into the school. It's very competitive. But one of the teachers there, Mordecai Loner, said, oh, I used to teach with Sandy Meisner.
I took with him, then I taught with him. You know, I'll help you on audition if you want to go to New York and audition for NYU. And then check in with Sandy Meisner. I did Sandy Meisner. I lied about my age. You weren't supposed to be 17, but I said I was a year older than I was. I got in and that's what happened.
I went to the neighborhood playhouse in 1970 when I graduated high school and at 17, just turning 18 that fall, started that course. That's cool. You always hear stories about people lying about their age to get in the Army, never to get into theater school. Yeah.
But no college, Jeff? No college. Good for you. Being in that college for six weeks, that was it. Jason and I respect that. Yeah, well done. Well, that's good, but this was a fancy two-year program of if you really wanted to be an actor, and I think,
and they used to, Sandy Meisner and other people that imitated him have a jaundiced eye make kind of comments about the college programs. He did at the time, going, mm, that's not where you learn to act. We from the group theater know what we're doing and they require you to be a little more cerebral and academic and this is about, this is a real studio
and I'm gonna teach you the real thing. And he was that real thing and I was imbued with that. That's so cool. Talk to me about, is this true, one of your survival jobs was to do office supplies for prisoners, like to get them office supplies? As you said. Like how in the world did that?
Sharp pencils and things like that. Yeah, like how in the world did you get that job? He had to blunt them, He had to blunt them. He had to blunt them. Here's what happened. That's a nice red drink you're drinking there, Jason. Oh, thank you. It's just red wine that's spoiled.
Really? No. No, it's electrolytes. I like a nice, oh, I see it's like a Gatorade. I like a nice mocktail these days. Yeah. You know, I've enjoyed a couple of those recently. I think they're starting to get that down.
All these restaurants have on the menu, you know, ooh, they're good. They're really good. But the answer to the question, oh yes, so I lucked into, like I say, a couple of jobs to Gentlemen of Verona. The first thing I did on stage at the Delacorte was a big hit, Raoul Julia was in it,
Galt McDermott wrote the music. I was in the chorus, I just kind of lucked into that. And then it went to Broadway. I stopped the second year with Sandy Meisner, did this year on Broadway as one of the chorus members and understudied one of the bigger parts, and then went back and finished that second year work with Bill Esper, who people may know.
So I did that and then auditioned for a play, I'll Grind It to Coca-Cola, got that, and then Altman saw me in that, and I auditioned for my first movie, which was Death Wish, and I started to work right away, in other words. And I was even supporting myself and all that, except when I came to California, and this is four years later after doing Nashville
and a couple other things, and kind of moved out here and got an agent, Abby Greschler. There was a moment when I was paying rent and my money was getting low and I thought, geez, I looked in the trade papers and they said, hey, you an out of work actor, you wanna make a little money, come and do this thing.
So I joined this boiler room operation, which I guess is illegal, at six in the morning, you go to Hollywood and you go to this place and you call correction institutions on the East Coast and you say, hi, I'm Bob, and we have a government surplus program just went bust, and we have a surplus of magic markers and pens and pencils. Can I send you, do you use the green or the red
or the blue? Can I send you a gross of the, you know, and you get them to commit to that is my least favorite thing. And maybe not coincidentally, after a week of that was only my straight job ever, after a week of that, I got this illness. I wound up in the hospital.
I'm just too sensitive for that kind of regular work. And after that, I went back to supporting myself, luckily, and ever since, with acting. That's amazing. Well, Jeff, so you're saying that selling the markers wasn't a highlight of your career. Oh! Yes!
Why not, why not, why not, why not, why not, why not, wow! I didn't get that at first. Wow, that's very good. You guys are sharp as tacks. It was a... It's a tick, it's a tick. By the way, remember Cats and Dogs? We did that movie together,
although we weren't on screen together. Remember that movie? I have, look, I know, I have, these are all the things I want to talk to you about, but I wrote down several things. Notes for you, Sean. Well, several things that overlap with us, connections that we have.
And I have, not only Will and Grace, but Cats and Dogs and so, really? Okay, watch this. So here it is. I have Sean Hayes. Hey, I like that. I like just free associating anyway. Anyway, now here's our connections.
Oh my God, well, Will and Grace, Cats and Dogs. Hey, well of course you portrayed Jerry Lewis and I was supposed to play his son in that last movie he did, Max Rose. Oh wow. Which Kevin Pollak finally did because I had a scheduling thing but Jerry and I hung out in order to bond
at his office in Las Vegas for a day. And that was fascinating because I had grown up with his, I kind of adored him early on. Yeah, yeah, same. Wait, Sean, when did you play Jerry Lewis? 2000. And in what? 99, 2000. What can I see this in?
A movie, I don't know where it is. It was Jeremy, Jeremy Northam. Northam. Okay, okay. He played Dean Martin. So it was about the duo and they're getting together and they're breaking up, I'm so fascinated. I've read a lot about that.
What film is this, Sean? Why are you trying to bury it? It's called Dean and Jerry, I don't know. It was a long time ago. Dean and Jerry. And where is it streaming? Is it on Tubi? Because Jason doesn't get Tubi, he's not sure. Well hang on, I don't know. It was a long time ago. Dean and Jerry, and where is it streaming? Is it on Tubi? Because Jason doesn't get Tubi, he's not sure. Well hang on, I don't know.
Do I get, do I have Tubi? Oh my God, what's that? Oh Martin and Lewis it's called. Martin and Lewis. Was this a TV film? CBS, yeah it was CBS. Oh it was a CBS TV film. Well that's why you're being cagey about it.
Okay, so listen. I love that, so I don't know if we can talk. No I didn't remember that until he just told me, Scottie just told me. I want to talk about though that comedy duo. I want to talk about Jerry, I want So listen. I love that, so what do I know? I didn't remember that until he just told me, Scottie just told me. I want to talk about that comedy duo, I want to talk about Jerry, I want to talk about Dean, but talking about you guys, how about the trios, how about, which brings me to the three stooges, of course,
and there's the Marx Brothers. Yeah, yeah. And how about applause. Bravo, I loved it, I loved it. That's commitment, what commitment? Are you kidding me? Bravo, I loved it. I loved it. What commitment? What commitment? Are you kidding me? Bravo. I loved that.
I believed him. I believed every moment of that deal. I was a-threads-ported, oh my God. I was. Now wait, the Three Stooges. I loved when I was a kid. I saw all of their things on television, but listen to this.
I saw them live. They came to a place called the Holiday House in 1960. It must have been, you know, two or five or something. And I saw Mo and Larry and Curly Joe at that time. And they came into the audience, I remember, and my sister, two years younger than me, was like five or six or seven. Mo, who had big bags at that point,
did something to her, kind of aggressive. She burst into tears. And she kind of retreated. He later got his eyes done and didn't have that problem anymore. Wow. Different Moe, different Moe, different Moe. Hey, promises, promises.
Oh my God. Jerry Orbach was the original. I love you. And by the way, Jay. I went three times! And you came backstage, and I appreciated that, so thank you. Oh, now we're full circle, now we're full circle.
He doesn't remember. All right, let's move on to Jason and Will, or I have a bunch of questions for you. Oscar Levant, listen to this though, my grandmother, Anna Katz, claims she dated Oscar LeVance, who's also at Pittsburgh, on one occasion. I don't know if that meant he flirted with her, if they had some encounter, I don't know what that means.
But anyway, that's our connection. Sean, you did not discover that during your extensive research? I shouldn't, but I'll use it. Okay. Will Arnett arrest the, well, I saw every episode of Arrested Development. And by the way, you...
Bravo! Bravo! Sean did? I know, it's on the Fox Network! Ah, it's amazing! Sean's character goes, what channel was it on? Yeah, exactly. We didn't find it. But I saw it, but I loved all your,
every character in it of course, Eliza Minnelli, I knew a little bit. And Charlie's Theron, fantastic. But the magician, the magic in that, and I know you've talked about magic before. I did magic in that movie Nashville, and in Wicked I do a little magic. So we could talk about magic.
You are magic. You are magic. I bet you strike me, Jeff, as the kind of guy who knows a few card tricks and a few sleight of hand things, do you? Yeah. I know, well, Robert Alton told me to learn some. I had this guy in New York taught me a bag full of tricks.
I brought it to Nashville and we used a bunch of them. The only thing that I've kept up my sleeve are these rope tricks. Oh, boy. Yes, which I've pulled out too many times, and I know that and then I know one card trick. That's all I know, but the rope tricks I can do. The rope tricks.
The rope tricks. That's always tough. You gotta make sure you're in a big group for that. So Jeff. I'm pitching that as a halftime show at the Super Bowl. I think those close-up magic would go over well. Sure. We'll be right back.
And now, back to the show. I want to talk about the famous Jeff Goldblum delivery, which is like, you're known for, it's brilliant, it's made you work. Don't break it down, don't break it down, don't break it down. What do you mean? That's a magic trick.
No, I thought this was interesting. I read that innovation body snatch of the Body Snatchers, kind of when you kind of discovered this thing, and it was the line, I never thought they would come in metal ships. Is that right? Yes. And now I would say it,
I would have never thought they'd come in metal ships, but you would say it. I never thought they'd come in metal ships. I don't know, I'm not making that up. I have no idea. That's really good. By the way, that's really good. That's good. I'm doing a caricature of? I don't know, I'm not making that up. I have no idea. That's really good, by the way, that's really good. I'm doing a caricature of my own, you know, Fumfuture-ing, I don't know.
I don't know what it is. I love that. But it was at that moment that Phil Kaufman said, oh yeah, that's good, I like the way he did that, and I kind of thought to myself, hmm, check note to self, I think, ah, that's something, that's something I can build upon. It's so cool.
Something like that. Anyway, so there we go, Horton Here's a Who. Oh boy, I love it. Legos, My Kids and Legos. Now, Ozark, wait a minute, wait a minute. You know, I did this series recently, Chaos, I played Zeus, and you know who played my wife? Janet McTeer.
Oh boy, she's a beast. She's wonderful. She's beast. She's wonderful. She's incredible. She's incredible and you know who I know a little bit, have not seen her since. When she was like, what, 12, 13, 14, something like that I think, or 15, this girl came backstage,
I think this is how it happened, to see me in the pillow man, I did this thing at the Booth Theater with people you know, I enjoyed doing that. So she came back, I think this is how it happened, to see me in the pillow man, I did this thing at the Booth Theater, with people you know, I enjoyed doing that. So she came back, I think then, and said, oh, I like what you do, you know, I wanna be an actress. Maybe, could we talk sometime? And you'll tell, you know, like I have a script,
we could, you know, read something, or, and you'll tell me, I said, sure. She seemed like an interesting and smart girl. That was Julie Garner. Oh wow. Wow. Really? And I have not seen her since.
I haven't seen her. To congratulate her on everything that's gone on. She's interesting, isn't she? Oh yeah. What a sweet, sweet person. Just a monster talent. Oh my gosh. Well, you know, and then of course,
hey, we did the switch, you and I, Dr. Baking. We played Best Friends, yeah. Best Friends. In the switch with Miss Jennifer Aniston, directed by the great. Miss Jennifer Aniston. Yeah, Will Speck, Josh Gordon. And Will Speck and Josh Gordon,
who directed me in some of these apartments.com commercials. I adore them. Is that right? No kidding. By the way, I love those commercials. Will Speck and Josh Gordon, who directed Blades of Glory, that I did years ago. Bravo, I love that. It Speck and Josh Gordon, who directed Blades of Glory that I did a few years ago. He's involved in this degrees of separation.
That's right. Jeff, who were your, you know, you hear these stories about actors like these, like the great Gene Hackman just passed away, and you hear like he was roommates with Robert Duvall and Dustin Hoffman. And then you hear these different people who came up. Who were sort of your gang?
Did you have like a gang of actor friends that we didn't know about, or like people who worked a lot and you guys were all coming up at the same time, or was it a more solitary existence for you? Meaning, did you have no friends? You know, I fit into the more solitary category. Yeah, really? Yeah. Are you an introvert or an extrovert? You know, I fit into the more solitary category. Yeah, really? Yeah.
Are you an introvert or an extrovert? Do you mind your business and stay in a dark room by yourself, like me? Well, I like time, I have my homework. I'm a good boy and I'm conscientious and I play the piano for an hour every morning and I work out and I like to work on my things. I'd rather not, I don't go to, I don't stay up late
in order to hang out or all of that stuff. So, you know, there's that. But I'm also- You can be friends with us by the sound of it. Yeah, exactly. You can be friends with us. Yeah, you're hard workers, obviously. But I adore people and I, you know, like I said,
I can imagine being pals with you and I have a good friend, Gary and Ed Begley Jr. is a good friend of mine. I love him. I love him. From the rest of the band, we love Ed Begley so much. We love him. Now, are you a concert pianist like our friend Sean Hayes?
He's a incredibly accomplished jazz pianist. I don't know, I'm a humble student, but I do like the jazz. I started off getting the chops playing Charney and John Thompson's stuff. And this and that, and then discovered the fake books and now called the real books and jazz, and I fell in love with that, and that's what happened.
And then 30 years ago, now I put it in some movies, the fly character plays the piano, and in Earth, Pearls, and Reeds, and I play the piano. Yes, that's right. And in plays, I put it in a couple of plays, and then 30 years ago, Peter Weller said, hey, we did this movie by Kerbanzai,
he said, let's get together and play a little bit, and then a couple of people, Miles Davis, who he knows, and said, oh, you and Jeff should go out and play a gig, and you'll get better and enjoy it, and that's what we started to do. So 30 years ago, I've had this group, Peter Weller kind we started to do. So 30 years ago I've had this group, Peter Weller kind of went off and did wonderful things but I've kept this group.
Peter Weller who also worked with David Cronenberg on Naked Lunch and who's also a cousin of Fred Weller, my good friend, theater actor. Love Fred Weller, I saw him on a play, I saw him on stage but how about speaking of the movie game. So Naked Lunch takes us to Judy Davis. I've never met her, but I adore her. She's great, yeah.
I'm a big fan of hers. Which takes us to husbands and wives, which takes us to Sidney Pollock or many other people. You had a role in Annie Hall as well, so that takes us where we're going. Sure did. So wait, Jeff, has jazz music, like playing jazz music, have you ever had to make a decision
about doing acting work over your music? Or do you always kind of make sure everything's separate? Separate, they went on parallel tracks. Like I said, at 10, I had my heart set on being an actor in my life as a career. Like have you ever turned down a big movie because you're like, I can't, I have a gig. Nope, nope, I have not.
As a matter of fact, I have gigs coming up. We have our fourth album on deck and we're coming out April 25th. And so in support of that, we're going to these places to play. We're gonna play the Palladium in London. We're gonna be in Toronto at Massey Hall, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
Give us some dates on those. Do you have dates on those, Jeff? Let's get a plug in here. April 25 Hall, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera. Give us some dates, give us some dates on those. You have dates on those, Jeff? Let's get a plug in here. April 25th, this may, by the time people hear this, may be too late, but we will have been at the Palladium and my two boys who play the piano, and I work with them, they have a great teacher, but I work with them, are gonna come on stage with,
it's a surprise, nobody knows yet, they're gonna come on stage with me and play something. I hope that's not abusive. I hope they have a good experience. And that's what it's for. Anyway, we'll be there, then Luxembourg, we go and then on the 26th, April, then May 25th, Atlanta, Symphony Hall,
May 27th to the 31st, we'll be at the Cafe Carlisle in New York City. You've been to Carlisle? Of course. I've played there before. I saw you play at the Troubadour, I think a long, long time ago. You're mixing me up with Bob Dylan or something.
No, no, I've never played at the Troubadour. Then it was somewhere else in LA. It was like a, I just, anyway, it was incredible. I've been all over the LA, yes, and I did a play at the Whiskey-a-Gogo down the block from the Troubadour, believe it or not. El Granado de Coco, yes, it was a cabaret theater. Any good theater stories from the Whiskey-a-Go-Go down the block from the play. Believe it or not, Elgrinat-a-Go-Go, yes, it was a cabaret theater. Any good theater stories from The Whiskey-a-Go-Go?
Anything happen there that was, Sean, sorry to cut into your moment of long. Jeff, I always ask people if you have any crazy, like, mishap theaters. I know you do. All right. I know you do. Well, I did the Moony Shapiro songbook,
which there were five of us, Judy. Garland. Gary Beach was in it. Gary Beach. Yeah of us, Judy, Gary Beach was in it. Gary Beach. Yeah, Gary Beach, of course. He was there, just five of us, singing and dancing. We were at the Morosco Theater, and we were rehearsed for four weeks. We previewed for two weeks, opening night.
It seemed to go well. The reviews came out. They weren't so great for the play. I got nice reviews. And then Stuart Ostro called me up and said, so, we're not gonna be doing it anymore. What, what do you mean? Well, Tuesday, well, Tuesday, this coming Tuesday,
we're off tomorrow or Monday, no, no, no, that's all, we didn't sell enough advance tickets, and the reviews didn't, so it closed opening night. So that's a kind of a, I don't know how funny that story is, but. So wait's the kind of a, I don't know how funny that story is. So wait, so Jurassic Park, I just want to talk for two seconds because I was so jealous when you,
I was signing a talk show and you had your own lyrics to the melody and I had my own lyrics that I was singing for years and years and it was. Oh shit, put a wallet in his mouth. Sorry. And do you remember yours yours mine went like this. Kill the dinosaurs, kill the dinosaurs, kill them all before they eat you.
And that was all I had. And then you came on and I was because it's... And you had years to work on that yourself? It begs for lyrics, doesn't it? Fuck, yeah. I don't know if it begs for it, but here's mine. Here's all I know. In Jurassic Park, scary in the dark, I'm so scared that I'll be eaten.
That's good. Bravo. This is a lyric. Now, Jeff, with all of the films that you've done, all the projects that you've done, you've done it all. The way that you choose what job to do, has it changed over the years since you've checked so many boxes?
Like, what gets you to work? What gets you to say yes nowadays? A good question. Well, it's always fluid, as you know, and that's always clarifying itself as the days and the weeks go on. But now, as I have this family, which I adore, and these two little boys,
it's not just for any reason that I'm gonna go off to the ends of the earth for a year, or do all sorts of things. So it has to be special, and my own criteria, you know, when I was, when Sandy, I took to heart what Sandy Meisner said, and it takes 20 years of constant work and then a lifetime of continual work if you get opportunities to keep growing,
and that's a good worthwhile way to spend your life. I took that to heart. But I went through a couple of decades where I worked a lot and wanted to work and wanted to work more and exercise myself and test myself and find out what I had in me and et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
Now, yes, I have as big an appetite as ever for creative, the creative experience so-called. But I don't have to, I don't have to work every day. I don't feel ashamed if I'm not working every day. That's okay. And so I wanna do special things, special, special things, whatever that means. But talk about that, what I thought you were about to say
about you went through a period where it was all about testing yourself. So that was kind of what drove your decisions. And now are you feeling like, I don't wanna put words in your mouth, but it's not like you don't have things to prove to yourself anymore, but is it less of an urgency?
Like, yeah? Yes, it's less urgent, although in another way, more urgent, because as we know, time is running out, and I still feel like I'm doing my best work. I feel at the top of my form, I'm injury-free, and I feel like I'm doing my best work. I feel at the top of my form, I'm injury free, and I feel like I'm enjoying it more than ever, I'm freer than ever, and can do my best work.
So I feel like grand things could be ahead. And you've satisfied whatever sort of personal doubt might be the wrong word, that whatever you were working through there and sort of having fun exploring, now you've sort of found this place of, not satisfaction, but just sort of like, I feel...
Content. Thank you. And now work takes on a different role, perhaps. I'm asking all this because I feel like I'm playing with it myself. Well, you're intuitive. You're a good therapist, you're a good friend. Well, we talk about it all the time, don't we?
Like the balance and what are the things that truly make us happy, right? And the way that we measure our happiness or our joy, it evolves over time, especially when you add sort of kids and family and experience and age and all those things. Work represents a different thing in different decades. Yeah, yeah, yeah. All of that. we could talk about all of that at length, but yeah that I I'm in the same ballpark
That's that's right and movies we could talk about it over on smartless after hours our new podcast Well, I like this long form this long form is great to me I mean I like the six seven minutes you spend on these talk shows. And you know, that's another kind of thing which would be fun to talk about. But I like these, I like listening to them. It's more of a conversation. Yeah, I love it too.
Yeah, I do too. And then we're gonna end on, by the way, thanks for being in Italy and talking to us for an hour. I mean, this is incredible. I mean, I can't believe it. What time is it there? It is, you know, say, oh, a quarter of eight. Oh, that's not a good time. The kids are already, I can't believe, what time is it there? This, it is, you know, it's like, oh, a quarter of eight. Oh, that's not it.
The kids are already, I know, I said hello, but they're now in bed. So it's two. No, no, no. No. Oh, sorry, two, but I'm sorry, I was thinking, two is a quarter of eight. All right.
Oh, yeah, quarter of eight. Well, it was Sharpie today. Yeah, look at that. Wow. Sorry. Anyway, hey, you know who sings on our new album is Scarlett Johansson and Ariana Grande and Cynthia Erivo. They have songs.
Half are instrumentals and half are singers, and they sing. How about that? That's incredible. Now, Wicked was probably as successful as everyone thought it might be, thank God and deservedly so. There is a second one coming that you've already shot
or that you're going to shoot? No, no, we've already shot it. We shot them all at once, but they're editing it and scoring it and special effectsing it. And a fun process, I'll bet, despite all the special effects and the wardrobes and all those things. Wardrobe, it was fantastic, you know,
he won an Oscar for that. Yeah, that was great. But John M. Chu is a delightful director and a very, very masterful director and that cast and Jonathan Bailey, whom I saw here in Richard the Second the night before, the Seagull show, by the way, he was terrific, and Ariana and Cynthia, it was aull show, by the way. He was terrific, and Ariana and Cynthia.
In fact, it was a magical and great, great experience. I loved that show when I first saw it with Idina Menzel and Kristin Chenoweth, and cried my eyes out at that, and so I loved playing that. Joel Gray played the part originally on stage, you know. Oh yeah? Yeah, it's great, yeah. Well, just great congratulations on that huge success. big congrats. Yes, that's amazing.
You're a Titan. It's always so fun to see you in anything. So when you pop on the screen, you're like, ah, I'm gonna be taken care of. Truly, truly, you elevate, you raise all boats, my friend. You raise all boats. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Thank you.
Well, you are so fun, this is a great honor. I hope we see each other often and immediately. Get back to this country. But I know now comes the part of the show. I'll say my farewells. And now, nobody's sung this song because you always say nice things afterwards and you have a little recap and a debriefing.
But you know that song? Please don't talk about me when I'm gone. Yeah, you know that song? Please don't talk about me when I'm gone. Yes, of course. That's a good thing. And then of course, do you know that song from Oliver? You know any songs from Oliver, Shawn?
Well, who will this glory be? No, I know as long as he needs me. Yeah, but who will I this glory be? Who will I this glory be? I don't know, I don't know. What is it?
Who will buy. Buy. Oh, Jeff Goldwyn. Wait,. What is it? Who will buy? Oh! Oh! Shafko! Wait, what are the words? Who will buy what? Who will buy this floor is something, something, something. Who will buy this drop, da, da, da, da.
Okay. Thank you, I guess has never given us a buy. Given us a buy, okay, well now you've given us so good. I love it. You've given us an out. And of course, I sung on one of those albums, I sang, little man you're crying, I know why you're blue, which is a version of a, what you sing to your kids
when they go to bed, a, lullaby. Oh! There's another one. Save it, save it, save it, save it, save it, save it. He's waving goodbye. All right, Jeff, thank you so much. Thank you, we love you. I love you so, so much.
Goodbye, I'll see you soon. Bravo, bravo, bravo. Bravo, bravo, bravo. That was amazing. Yeah, he's great. Jeff Goldblum. We didn't even get to Wes Anderson. He's worked with all the greatest directors, Wes Anderson, Steven Spielberg.
Something like 80 films or something. It's like it's insane. Like almost no bad ones. No, almost no bad ones and always happy. Always happy. Always happy. And again, another one of those never a bad performance. Yeah, almost no bad ones and always happy. Always happy. Always happy. And again, another one of those never a bad performance. Yeah, you never catch him acting. He's just always doing, he's got his own rhythm
and you know what I think, you were right not to sort of dissect his thing and not that I would know how, but if I were to guess. Well, no, I only did it because I read that he likes to talk about it. Well, but it's like, you can see the next thought coming into his head and so he races through the old thought to get to the new, like, he's always like, that's it.
I don't know, I try to do, I try to think about what I'm gonna say before I say it, which is how the brain works, you know? But in acting, you have the line in front of you. You know what's coming and that's the missing point. You have to sort of like get the thought first. But sometimes don't you feel like, I didn't want him to share it.
Like you don't want to know too much how the sausage is made. And Sean, correct me if I'm wrong. You just want to enjoy the sausage. Sausage, that is correct. Right. Yeah, just the sausage, correct. Yeah, that is right.
That is correct. You can keep the casing on it or cut the casing. It doesn't matter. You can be cut or untied. Massage the casing and make sure it's all evenly. Oh boy. Boy, that took a real turn, man. I tell ya.
That took a real turn. What about the, what's that song from Oliver you said? What was it? Who Will? No. Bye. Oh no. No, I think the better image is just sort of like
a nice peaceful house there in the Italian countryside. Yeah, and the families go into bed. Yeah, the kids go, you go to sleep, you go to sleep. And then you might sing them something, right, Sean? How would that song go? Like what? La la bye and good night. Oh my god.
You got somewhere you gotta go? Yeah, that's lazy. I mean... La la bye. Here we go. La la bye. Say la la bye. Bye.
Or you know what? Just bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry and Rob Armjarf. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.